hello
and welcome to this talk my name is
leonardo lagunas
and we're going to talk about modeling
analog synthesizers
but before we start this is a little bit
of information about me
during the day i work as software
developer and in the system modular team
but during the night i am the jack of
all trades
at my own project which is called vult
where i
develop software and hardware for music
technology
and one of the things that i enjoy the
most is modeling
vintage analog synthesizers specifically
the electric circuits that you can find
in them
and why do we bother modeling all these
old analog equipment
well you may have hear people saying
that
the sound of vinyl record players is
much better
than mp3 player
and that is true and not true at the
same time
so the the thing with the analog
synthesizers
is that they produce a sound that can be
perceived as
warm and rich it's it's more appealing
compared to the to the early digital
synthesizers
that were producing sound that was
perceived as cold
and lifeless in the the secret here it
lies in the imperfections of the analog
synthesizer
digital synthesizers use some kind of
computing element
it can be for example a microprocessor
and this
microprocessor has a near perfect
arithmetic so
every multiplication every addition
has a very good precision on the other
hand
an analog synthesizer is made with
components that
have imperfections and these
imperfections accumulate
they use for example semiconductors
which are
non-linear components and these
components
saturate and they they also have
variability
not every resistor has exactly the same
value
here we have an example of a
digital oscillator that produces a show
wave
you can see how it it nice it looks
and if we compare this saw it against an
analog oscillator you can see
how different it is even even when we
are
i mean to have a soul wave it is not
a subway it's it's slightly different
and this difference is part of what
makes it appealing
and a big part of what i do is trying to
create the simulation models that
replicate these imperfections
going back to the vinyl record player
we could make a regular cd player
a sound as appealing as a final record
player if we add
the required signal processing in order
to match the
sonic characteristics and how do we
start modeling
analog synthesizers first let's take a
quick look
on how they are architected so a typical
analog synthesizer
is composed by different blocks or
modules
they can be oscillators filters
amplifiers and other modulators so
basically you can think about them as
being
analog computers and these analog
computers perform
additions multiplications comparisons
integration and we can say that they
even perform
trigonometric operations here you have
two pictures of
of two different systems this one
you can see that it has a panel where
where
the different modules are laid out
so we have oscillators filters etc we
have a keyboard
and then we have this section that
allows us to
change the internal connections of the
components
on the right hand side we have a fully
modular synthesizer
and you can see that it is composed by
different blocks and each of these
blocks is independent and can be
replaced and you have all the controls
but you can also connect in
in any way you want each of these
modules you have jacks
and you can use wires to to create the
structure that that you want
the synthesizers can be a bit expensive
especially the modular ones where you
get
every module separated and the cost of a
module
could be in the range of 60 dollars to a
thousand dollars
and they can also be a bit bulky and
heavy because we have to put them inside
a case so they are not very
practical to travel with them one way
that we can overcome these problems is
by using a virtual synthesizer
for example vcv rack which is a
software that is free and open source
and
it tries to simulate the experience of
using a modular synthesizer
here you can see some of the modules
that i make which are real modules
and the equivalence in the in the pcb
rack world
in the virtual synthesizer world you can
have as many
as you want and the the cost is not a
problem but you are also
losing a bit which is which will be the
the interaction in a real synthesizer
you can touch all the controls and and
perform with them
while in a virtual synthesizer you are a
little bit constrained
because you need you need to use the
mouse or or you have to use a controller
in order to help you move the components
now i'm going to give you a quick demo
on how to create
a sound using a modular synthesizer
this is the vcbrack interface and i have
already placed a few modules
and i'm going to create a sound using a
technique called subtractive synthesis
so i'm going to start with a with an
oscillator
that sounds like this
i'm going to change it to a soul wave
and as you can hear is it's it's a sound
that has a lot of harmonics
and next we're going to pass this
oscillator
through a filter
[Music]
you can hear how the how the filter
shapes the sound i'm going to take this
this model that i made which is a
it's a mechanical model it's not an
electrical but it simulates a
chaotic pendulum system we're going to
use it to provide some modulations to
to our oscillator
[Music]
now we have a sound that that varies
over time
is not a static sound and next thing
that i'm going to do
is taking this output and we are
introducing it into into
an envelope generator which is going to
allow us to
to trigger the sound
[Music]
and now we have a sound
that has its amplitude modulated
to make it longer
[Music]
shorter
with a softer entrance
[Music]
and we can add we can modulate as well
the filter
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
and now let's take a look at the process
i use to create the simulation models
behind these modules i usually start
my analysis with the schematic like in
this case this is a filter
and i start by identifying the different
blocks and components
and at the same time i'm developing a
board that i use
for actually making measurements like
this one
sometimes i simply make the circuit
into a breadboard once i have identified
all the components
i start making the modeling system
modular
since the model provides a wide variety
of components
that can be used in my case could be
electrical components for example
resistors capacitors etc
but one of the things that that i really
really like about
using system modular is that i can
create my own components
it is often the case in other simulators
that
a component is not provided and there is
no easy way of integrating it or
creating it
or sometimes the the way that you create
the components it's kind of convoluted
over the years i have created a library
of components
i have a small version here and you can
see that i have
typical components resistors capacitors
variables
variable resistors and operational
amplifiers
and these are the components that i use
to create the circuits
now let's start on analyzing a simple
circuit
in this case we're going to see the
salinki
filter topology we're going to focus on
the low pass configuration
and this is the circuit you can see that
it uses two resistors
and two capacitors and it has an
operational amplifier
which is connected as a buffer and from
these equations
we can see that in order to define the
cutoff frequency
we need to either change
the resistors of the or the capacitors
and
if we make the two resistors the same
value and the two capacitors this gets
simplified and we can simply
use a pair of variable resistors in
order to define
the cutoff in system modular i have
already connected all the components
into the salinkey filter configuration
you can see two resistors two capacitors
and one buffer but these resistors
are one of my models which are variable
resistors and both
are controlled by this input signal p
the audio is provided with this input
signal u
and then is converted into voltage
and at the output i have a sensor
which is going to measure the filter
voltage and provided in the
output v now i'm going to test this
filter
i have prepared a model here which
this is this is my filter model the one
that i the one that i described before
i'm using a component from the modelica
library which produces a pulse wave
and then i'm using a software which is
slower that i'm going to use
to change the cutoff frequency of filter
the output is going to be
sent into this into this model that is
going to record
the the results and it's going to
generate
an audio file that we can listen
we can see that simulating a model like
this one can take quite some time
in this case 25 seconds and that is
because
by using the audio recorder we are
forcing the simulator to take
44.1 kilo samples per second
if we remove the recorder the simulator
will be able to go in much faster
but one of the nice things of doing this
is that we can listen directly to the
audio results
now let's see how we can extract the
equations of this
simple filter model and create a
model that can run in real time since i
have packed my filter model into a
single component
it will be much easier to extract the
equations
used only into this component but before
before doing that let's check one nice
feature
what i did it was simulating only the
filter component since it doesn't have
any input
it will not produce any signal but the
nice thing is that we can go to the
tools
and use the equation browser in
simulation center without going into too
many details
what we can see it's it's a it's a
matrix that has one diagonal
and in all the all the colors of these
small boxes are green
what this means is that every all the
equations are
easily solved one after the other
just to have a reference let's take a
look at a more complicated filter like
this one
we can see that in this case we have
non-linear blocks the ones that are
orange
and they are quite big and we also have
some linear blocks
what this means is that it is going to
be a little bit more difficult
to create this model since we will have
to to run
a non-linear solver in order to solve
the the equations and that can be very
expensive in real time
just keep that in mind the mod the model
that we are analyzing now it's linear
and it's going to be easy to
do in order to retrieve the equations
we're going to use
a system model to get into information
about
the filter component
now that we have the model we can get
the equations
you can see that i use the method
elimination all and what this is going
to do is going to remove
automatically most of the simple
equations leaving us with
equations that actually do some
computation now we can simplify even
further
these equations by using the command
eliminate
and one thing that we want to do is to
eliminate the currents
since the currents do not provide us in
any extra information
we can just get rid of those
okay i think that i have got rid of all
the currents and we can also get rid
of voltage calculations we don't care
for example we don't care about the
voltage in the resistors
at this point we only have the voltages
in the capacitors the inputs
and the outputs and i'm going to do
some replacements in order to compact
the equations even more
now we're representing the derivatives
as dw1 and dw2
and since this system is quite simple we
can
represent it as an ode
and these are the all the equations
we're going to prototype our
implementation
of the filter using rack
in a special mode called the vc
prototype that will allow us to use
the volt language which is a very simple
language that i developed
in order to express dsp algorithms
and here we are going to start writing
the code but first i'm going to copy the
differential equations that we got
and paste them directly in our code
once that we have calculated the
derivatives i'm going to use an
integration method in order to simulate
these differential equations
in this case i'm going to use the euler
method because it is
it's simple and it will be good enough
for this example
if you remember the parameter p
represents the position of the
potentiometer
it will directly control the cutoff
frequency
h in this case is going to represent the
simulation time step
finally i called the filter function and
i provide the p
and h which h is the inverse of the
sample rate and in the parameter p
i use an exponential function
in relation to the graphical position of
the node
this will help us to make a transition
in a musical way
rather than linear if everything is fine
i just need to save this file and we
will be able of using it
inside vcp rack and here is the code
running in vcp rack
let me raise the volume a little bit
[Music]
to summarize this talk we saw why analog
sounds are perceived as more pleasant
and we also saw that it is possible to
capture
that imperfection of the sound of the
analog electronics into models
i also show you how i use or from
language and system modeler
in order to make my modeling process
much simpler i can capture very large
schematics and
and analyze them using word from
language and system modular
when making this kind of models it is
very important to
note that they need to be very efficient
and wrong
in real time and when you have
nonlinearities the analysis can
get quite complicated and the biggest
reward for me
is listening to the music that the
people make with my models
and to close this presentation i'm going
to leave you with an example that my
friend ambry cohen made
hi i'm omri i'm a musician based in
germany
and my instrument is the modular
synthesizer in two forms
hardware and virtual the virtual part is
coming from
vc vrec a free and open source virtual
modular
synthesizer that is based on the
eurek format just like i have here for
me using a modular synthesizer is all
about the
interaction with the instrument live
acting and reacting
to the sounds i have a small patch ready
i will go through the modules and
devices i'm using
and the most important module here is
the es9
which is basically a dc coupled audio
interface
that allows me to send audio and control
voltage from and to
vcv rack and by that connect both worlds
virtual and analog i have here the first
voice coming from an oscillator
going through an effects module and it's
being sequenced by
this controller here so i just hit play
[Music]
another voice is coming from an audio
processor that chops
the audio into little grains also called
the granular processor and in this case
i just recorded me
doing this snapping my fingers
[Music]
another voice is coming from an audio
recorder
and that plays back the audio in reverse
starting at different points of the
recording
and plays different segments of the
audio
[Music]
another voice is coming from what is
actually an effects module
but with the right settings it can act
as an oscillator
and its amplitude is controlled by an
envelope
and it's being processed through another
effects module
[Music]
having another voice coming from a
so-called semi-modular
synthesizer going through two different
filters from volt
one and two and also through some
effects
[Music]
and as i mentioned before i'm using vcv
rack together with the hardware so in
vcv i have
another voice and coming from another
volt module that generates
sound and i control its filter and
amplitude with a midi controller that
i have here
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you